ladies and gentlemen welcome back
Leon Scott is joining me thank you for
every man thank you for having me thank
you for coming up it's making me feel
incredibly pale I'm not used to at the
co-host of the show jong-eun Youssef
once a powerlifter and one's a gymnast
so I'm not used to being the not not the
leanest person on the couch either but I
think they're competing with each other
today which is which is totally fine how
are you you good yeah I'm good me a very
good very good thank you brilliant you
recently moved football teams right
you're a new team I did man yeah that
would be town at the minute enjoying it
as a fuel I do I know they play they
have played there before so it's
returning club very friendly family
round club so yeah I'm enjoying it MIT
and they're it's good to be back and
join the football fantastic so for the
viewers and the listeners that don't
know you can you give us a little bit of
background about what it is that you do
you've got an interesting eclectic mix
of elements of your life and I want a
train yes give a nice background a bit
about my background well in terms of
sort of media wise how that sort of all
kicked off was I think he must have been
about seven eight yeah go I know I was
quite looking for tchen it was actually
funny or not as you've mentioned that
was clever would be town and how it all
started and I was playing for Whitby
town just normal football going about a
normal thing and there was a young guy
with an idea of a clothing brand back
then 7 8 7 8 years ago it wasn't really
a big thing back then well not many
people done it it was a now you see
every other person is making the floor
and Brenda but back then it was one
night only your Nike Adidas and so on
Assad and so yeah you got that he had an
idea he asked me would I model his brand
and back then I'd never done no
modelling I probably wasn't as confident
in front of a camera and so I said yeah
yeah let's give it a go
he was from Scarborough metal parts
Cobra and we just done a few shoots of
funny enough the brand now is probably
one of the biggest brands within the
industry that
didn't which not being sick silk hmm
well they are they were like the first
no yeah that back then no the first
people I believe they were the first
people do it was a big thing to get on a
reality TV star back there you know if
you could get on someone from geordie
shore from Charlie etc it was a big
thing now it's just the norm so he
managed to do that buckler and that's
all they wore I remember you know anyone
who remembers like the proper heyday
yeah Scotty T and guards and the earth
guys that was yeah so that was it and
that that was his big break because back
then they wanted to wear it it was it
was all kid to wear it no it's it's a
whole new way if yeah it's endorsements
xoxo
it's a the idea now so yeah so that
that's how it all started for me I
modeled for him and then more brands
approached me and Jim King be inspired a
lot of other big brands I think my big
break came from for Salim and they
approached me and asked me to do a
campaign out in beefer and for me it was
somewhat where I was wearing all this or
to go there and actually be paid and be
able to see yeah it was a bit when I
open up to because I do remember we were
doing a shoot in there in Ocean Beach
and it was all deer season so we've been
sectioned off in one corner trying to do
four with you and everyone else is in
Orchard Beach party and dancing and
roads and bridge abroad exactly giving
it this and a large a key first area
fears so yeah that was a bit of an
experience but from then it's just been
a complete snowball effect for me but on
top of that right at the start of always
worked full-time so it was quite a set
in an inked it off to go every because
my full-time job for six year was
working with people of autism and Down
syndrome
okay so although that was intense that
was really rewarding as well so when I
did get chance to do the photo shoots
for me it was Mother
not not so much of a d off but Marvel
like wow cannot as this
get appear that it wasn't didn't feel
like work yeah so obviously when I went
back to my normal dear work I was full
of energy and very grateful of of me
being able to do that when these guys
potentially maybe never experienced what
I was experiencing so I did find a lot
about myself in between Allah and I just
it was just like a complete snowball
effect you got a big contrast there
right so you know you're going to go and
work with people who've got learning
difficulties and real behavioral
problems and then you're going out to
some of the best party destinations on
the planet exactly so easy I mean that
will be must feel like a real contrast
it was it was I could say that that I
think that right the early stages is
where I did learn a lot about myself
because there was some jobs I had been
on and you know and every job I went on
I am still to this day like blown away
by me I'm getting paid for doing this
you know and I think that's when it all
started for me in terms of like
appreciate and then all that type of
stuff because when I went back to my
dear job you know it was just a complete
it was just two completely different
fields of area of work so when I was on
the model and type fig and there was
some people I did do jobs with and night
that didn't really fully appreciate what
they would do and I what they were given
are the opportunities of where the arm
what was going on it was still a bit of
a sometimes it's not yet achieved on the
model ominous and I was just sometimes
that really confused me with people and
to this day seven eight nine years
online I still try not to give that type
attitude you know because some people
when they aren't shoots that believe
I'll still think that model is the model
the model is the main person of the day
it's not it's like it's it's a
collection of everything you know either
at the behest of the show I mean you're
there to give whatever clothes it is
it's the guy that designed the course of
150 different sizes not the model
exactly is it
it's the brand that you work at with and
again and I believe that's what got me a
lot of work back not always my looks I
don't think it was it was it was the
impression I given on the deer and what
I'd give back and me appreciation and I
don't only just think that a lot of
people said that and you know we've we
loved working with you it was easygoing
it was we had a laugh it didn't feel
like work with us so I would like you to
come back and do another shoot I mean
you know it's nice it's nice to hear
that someone who goes into an industry
that is quite shallow by its very nature
like yeah you are there for your looks
yeah that if you do go for the go there
for that that people are still taking
notice of the way that you conduct
yourself and things like don't get me
wrong I think looks is a big thing you
see summer and you're a shock to with
trivia by the eye but if as nor if
there's nothing past that then it
doesn't keep you there I agree so what
was the actual role that you were doing
with people with learning difficulties
and people it was busy managing them to
live their everyday life what's the job
role tighten and support worker so our
support we're so it's busy that they
struggled to live in everyday life as we
do and things get brushed teeth get the
books go to college go to work and go to
doctors gospel or see family acceptor so
we we'd help them and support them
within that day and so I've got to work
out yet they'll get it we've won one
individual and out support and frog is
there made sure that he lived the life
as normal as he could with Vinnie's
means as everyone else you know kids
because they do struggle like they
wanted to go and visit parents what
Buster won't get where do I go we
support them with that and we'd make
sure they're like I said living life to
the fullest as much as that car you
employed by the NHS for them and it was
know it was accompanied by UVU the book
I believe the best in Harrogate what the
ugly they had about seven houses within
the northeast or so people lived on site
yes so it was a it was like a tenants of
sir it was a big house with five tenants
in and we had a staff team who said 10
or 15 people and obviously with us
there was different houses around the
area but the outside was based and
worked was they were all young and very
out gone because that's what I like not
that I did go to the / Alice's but there
I'm also the older range you like to sit
and watch Italian player bar games and I
think to get my full attention of my to
be able for me it deliver the best that
could I'd like to be my hands on and I
can know like pass on my fitness type of
thing you've got a football I brought
some to my football games took them to
the gym you know I mean try to push them
like a lot of them are young lads and
wanted to live like normal a book maybe
didn't have the confidence maybe didn't
have the support and that's what we were
there for that's awesome so you've
touched on it daddy you also play
football so we've gone through one part
of your life which is the the modeling
the Instagram done another which is a
support worker
yeah we're also semi-professional yes a
refresh no back down I was at Dallas or
that was quite intense I was a duns a
very high level for it was yeah we were
I was there for six year we won four
promotions in that year I was captain
for free year so it was a very
successful time at down and when a lot
of promotions the club got the went down
five leagues is a big story behind it
I've done if you're not aware of it back
then back then that way I think it was
bankrupts or they were in a big stadium
the drop down five leaves their benefit
ins right yeah that's right so the drop
down it's always been around like
professional club as I am got a bunch
bad word to say about the club you know
the the big fan base for a non league
team still getting like 1500 through the
gear which suddenly two clubs don't even
get up so yeah it was a very good time
there we won I said four promotions and
so it was a little bit a lot I see art
it was it was odd but it wasn't because
everything I was doing didn't feel like
it was odd if you got me like it wasn't
like I do like these guys I've got a
work and you know
bricky or whatever you wanna call like I
feel leg draft
I feel like that is hard work agreed I
think you know and so for everything I
was doing I was obviously modeling
flying around the world going to work
and in terms of support support work
help and young lads and then I was going
to football none of that felt like I was
really grafting apart from the only
towns where I was going in the gym yeah
and I was that was the only time where
it was coming well she ain't going I
feel naca via yeah but yeah we should
try to keep all the fries together and
keep them all tight because if one fell
I felt like it linked in in the over and
so on and so on so I needed to keep in
[ __ ] because of the modeler and I wasn't
allowed to get too big because of the
football you know and it wasn't allowed
to get too tight because then I'd
underperform at my job so like at
balancing act yeah it was out of people
sure how do you fit all in but is that
all blue sure there's 24 hours in a day
and you know some days where I've
traveled to London and arrived at 8
o'clock 11 o'clock at night
I've got me up at 7:00 and there's a
24-hour gym aslam in the hotel go down
show up quick 45 minutes after hour get
to bed
so I would always make sure you are a
done something to keep within a
feel-good factor because if I didn't I
felt affected me attitude and the way I
felt
so it was like what's your natural
personality what's your natural kind of
mindset like you know without you if
you've just got a normal day and you're
going about your business what's your
mindset like and then what's it like if
you don't train and then what's it like
if you get it really good do you have
swings and mood swings
I wouldn't say mood swings in terms of
dad I'd feel the more I tend to do the
more energy I've got the less I do the
less energy I've got so I like to stay
busy in terms of going to the gym being
productive if if I find myself sat
around doing nothing I feel I always
feel guilty almost obvious if it's time
wasted I find it are tissue tissue off
which magnet my girlfriend always says
just relax you know watch telly you're
allowed to do nothing and I'm like of
North Tom West's I can be region I can
be listening to podcasts I can be
working on someone I can be at the gym I
always feel like I've got to be doing
something and ever dawned I have learned
so I
sir which my mindful as allowed me to do
that I have learned to accept that it is
all care to do nothing
whereas in the past a digit or whoever
but there's still times when I do
struggle with it because I could say I
like being very active in learning and
progressing like what had an idea that
made me feel better I wouldn't dare to
improve or these are the type of
questions that I ask myself before I go
to sleep each night and if and if he
ain't got an answer any nine times out
of ten I have a bad sleep because I
can't wake up the next day to get after
it
yeah to change these aren't these
answers I've given myself yeah it's
interesting that there's a lot of
parallels that I can draw between your
experience of mine you know some of the
some of the listeners at home may be
surprised to hear that someone who is a
professional footballer and Instagram
model and you know flying around the
world modeling for brands that are worn
by party boys and party girls yeah it's
also one of your main concerns is what
sort of value am i adding to my life in
the life of lives of others yeah it
sounds quite contrary right yeah
different sort of yeah you can see why
people think that and look at Apple you
know I want which is the reason I did
release my two books it it was to give
some people back of what I've like done
myself and lamp myself test trial and
error you know I mean I always get which
goes back to my job of support living I
always get a kick out of helping someone
maybe progress or you know just just
chatting to someone in terms and what
can I help with if I can't maybe we can
just have a chat and this and you don't
have to take it in you know but I'm
always open to help and I want to well
cuz I get like a little buzz off like
that that person is as maybe learnt some
off me or maybe I've passed them on a
blend of someone else because I always
feel like although I like to give advice
I'm always wanting to learn as well I'm
not I'm never gonna be a mouse out with
all with that let the office in I'm
never gonna be a master always be a TF
Ilana you know I'm always wanting to
learn yeah so yeah you can see it
obviously that's I take my lifestyle
book if you take the headlines if you
take the headline semi-professional
footballer inside run wanker all the
rest of this stuff
flying around the world got a
good-looking girlfriend and going on
holidays and blah blah blah it's the
same for me like people say ex reality
TV star club promoter does the Instagram
thing like [ __ ] like you can sit and
that's not that's just that's just
painted on us by society booked them
things like it sounds crazy because I
still to this day I'm not a model
I just model yeah exactly I but I
generally believe that because I've
never thought that in my eyes models are
the guys that you know did do big
fashion shores decide to agencies the
working with these big billboards the
after Sheen for the watches to me that
guys are the models we've just me
personally and potentially like yourself
and potentially the other guys who do
that out there model we've just gained a
little bit of a fallen through social
media and now we're used to model
because if I will follow it because
these brands know that we've got an RN
follow and that's seen by a lot of
younger kids where's the the real models
with the agencies who are see they're
like they're not really used by the claw
of them runs but if the one of the main
things as well with my experiencing
especially in commercial modeling is
that the I'd love if someone knows the
statistics please comment below oh I
think that probably eighty to ninety
percent of what would be cast as
modeling work will be EECOM so it'll
just be some guy and a photographer and
maybe a stylist if you're lucky on an
infinitely bored in a studio just
shooting clothing shots any like because
that's the highest volume anyone who's
listening you've gone on a JD sports to
have a look at the new top the night top
that's just got it but whatever it might
be like that photo it needs to be
constructed and it looks like it's maybe
you know a two-second job it's actually
quite an arduous process to go through
and I think that that and you know
that's where the real that I always make
the job that's the only time they for me
model they never feels like work it
doesn't really feel that work when
you're on location it's always hard work
again I was still whenever I turned up
my always grateful
well I did turn up say up to get the
turn six in the morning to get a
Manchester tissue for for asylum and I'd
look up the real and have like about
40-50 t-shirts on the tee when it's
t-shirts as well it just feels like it's
not going down but you're an offer
you're not going to get such any any
models there listen they'll know the
feeling when you're looking at rail on
the other side of a and you just like
we've been going and then what you start
to do is you look at how much time we've
been in there for work out how the
government's you've shot extrapolate
that forward and then they let right so
I'm doing one t-shirt around about every
four minutes and 15 seconds so if I
really speed up video guide Dean's
pissing himself behind the camera cuz he
knows exactly the pain that we're
talking about yeah but it was one that
was back then I I had really long hair
so yourself like give it back so it was
like I have to really like slowly got my
teacher otherwise if I just walked it on
quick then enough to go at the makeup
and hair stylist would read to me yeah
so it was like a lot of protein crystal
me literally but yet then I'd look at
the real is that you were saying there
and although there was 50 t-shirts on
right right let's try a nil through all
be done by one
I'm from experience I do Latin then all
of a sudden they'll bring a number 50
and I'd be like [ __ ] that I'd be like
right I'm just gonna time until it gets
to four so they can bring it over before
you know I mean another thing as well
was it the sharp project where you went
for foot asylum where JD Sports shoot
the sharp project in Manchester where as
it media City know it might have been
the sharp who's out and destroy stuff
using a huge big thing yeah check in at
the front yet all gay yeah so for anyone
who doesn't know JD Sports own pretty
much all of the Pantheon blacks which
make outdoor retail outdoor gear light
trespass and North Face and stuff like
that they've got first island they've
got themselves etc etc and you have
never ever seen a facility like this so
you'll have infinitely wall shooting
studios you'll have models facing models
so you'll have two photographers working
away from each other if you can imagine
like an alleyway and at the end of each
alleyway is a model that's facing each
other
in the middle of the alleyways two
photographers facing away from each
other and then you've got another
alleyway next one it's like four of
these alleyways each with a stylist each
of the photographer and then as the rail
gets completed the photographer will
crop the photos to the particular aspect
that's required to go up online and then
there's a mezzanine level like a balcony
that overlooks where the digital team is
and something that you photographed 20
minutes ago will be up online ready
yourself yeah it is it's a [ __ ] force
it was like a circle to her just firearm
and stress so as soon as you shot it I'd
be back on the website when you see
something like that happened that's when
you realize just how sophisticated they
eat commerce industry oh no they're not
[ __ ] about no literally arrived and
its online so that that was just works
so quick or I can say I used to always
do every Thursday's that never set a
model for a certain look but they had
these shoots there nearly every deer you
know like this model suits this look so
we've got him for that they're this
massive so we've gotten for that they've
gotten they've got a set of analytics on
the backend as well where they track the
sales of garments based on the model
yeah and then they're like oh that this
particular guys selling a 5 percent
better than this person and then like
this is maybe for yourself as well as
someone who's kind of got a bit of a
hunger for learning [ __ ] like I had to
distract myself from wanting to
understand the operation that was going
on to actually focus on my job which was
getting the [ __ ] photos take is I
just I just want to be like alright so
where does this go oh my god and it's up
it goes straight up there and they can
put it on anyway how many do you do a
day like Chris can you just [ __ ] my
head so mom was the other side of that
as you were really inches that I was
always really interested in the
photographer site yeah so I would always
walk home and say ah I hoped you say of
doing that right right I know I that's
or just just which is where later in
life are progressing I've done
photography courses now okay so now I
know I've like I I saw and all this time
things but I'm not massively no not at
all but it was always something like wow
how she got that shot
you got that light there it's something
I've always wanted to learn and
progressing so yeah like you said you
got grandma's on the oxygen
yeah you've touched on the mindfulness
before and I think this is why me and
you probably have a lot quite a lot in
common
would you be able to explain the journey
that you've had with regards to
mindfulness and where you stayed and
what sort of learnings you've been
exposed to and stuff like that well I
wasn't very well being of that skill in
terms of I had a very short attention
span I couldn't really sit in class and
listen to much wasn't very good at
reading them right in so it was like I
used to always see people and all their
reading books I used to reasonable you
know like now I get it
was like was that as a kid maybe not as
a kid yeah of course that was a kid and
I just didn't get I used to think I'd
rather be bombing in the pool I'd rather
be at the bar like you're wasting your
time but the not now like I get it you
know I mean so it comes in to where my
first book was mayor motivation
manifesto by a random butcher and it was
like I read that and everything just
that had been so clear and makin sense
and then I download an app called car
which was free for seven days for anyone
listening maybe give it a go and add to
the fifth it's like 15 minutes of
meditation and the reason I enjoyed it
is because I put it into practice and it
worked at zero and it worked you know it
was like wow this [ __ ] really works like
I do it and what was getting taller I'm
like alright okay I'm gonna try that and
then I try and I'd get a good feel and
our good reaction bar so it was just
like it just it just progressed and then
from the app I started Google and
courses as a course and not far from me
and the main Buddhist monks sent and
down and there's a guy that comes around
our area every Monday and now our meet
up with him I've got very friendly with
him I've learned a lot off him
and and just he just when I walked into
the room my first I just remember my
first year when I went into the room and
actually actually it was I just looked
at having just without even speak and I
was just like you look so happy I like
you know like and
sit stylish stuff at the front and and
the waist told his stories he's just
chuckling at himself and and he said
like he's explained like a pro is a
problem really a problem that I've
caught in the deep I'm like no no like
what you are saying is powerful and it's
real it's you're like I've never read
this before I've never experienced this
before and he used to always say himself
like I ain't just saying this because I
want to say it I'm saying it because it
really works you know this this is this
this type of stuff actually works so try
it so I look at it was one of my I did
try it I put things into practice and it
and it just progressed and every time
like I do more I want to do more and
more and more and more so yeah that's
what I'll start and if it's and I'm
still on that journey now I you know I
want to learn more when I go deeper I
want to maybe travel and do more
meditation and learn more about it I
tried to stick to 15 minutes and there's
some guys out there that do two hours a
deal and I maybe I'm not under well I
don't think I know I'm not that stood
yeah even cuz it's hard but it's very
very good oh yeah get the book you know
I I do that to start don't get me run
out to start we we went to the class and
won me my best man when we first went
this but when I told you about and some
pass we did look at each other and
chuckling I know
but back then we look at any you know
and maybe that's why people don't do it
because the thing will close your eyes
the think it's all this type of stuff
but it's actually not it's it's working
on becoming a better person from within
you know and a lot of people want to
work on what looks good but a lot of
people are blind and I'm working on what
feels good fantastic fantastic point I
think one of the things that's super
interesting is that doing when you work
in an industry like modeling very
transactional very surface deep and the
whole Instagram thing it is awash with
people that have got undiagnosed mental
health problems or charisma issues or
insecurities that they're then
projecting on social media and something
that I always thought would be hilarious
would be if in some different iteration
of the world
we were able to have an Instagram that
instead of showing someone's outward
condition was able to represent
someone's inward condition and if you
were able to compare the person who's
got a lot of followers and looks happy
and it's always you know in a fantastic
place with on holiday taking forwards in
the sunshine and smiling and laughing
and he think ok if we were actually able
to flip that and show your internal
state
what sort of photos would we see from
that yeah and I think you told you right
the calm apps apps like headspace and
karma they were a great introduction
guided meditation is fantastic for
people who need to make an entry into
yeah in the meditation to hear that you
said that during two hours of day is
difficult and people think how you just
sing sitting along with the thoughts how
hard can it be
let me tell you I went and did a
meditation retreat in between Christmas
and New Year so there's a place at Bell
say appear Tibetan temple that we went
to go and do and myself and Yusef who's
done a ten day ten hours a day retreat
previously yes he was he was already
quite well conditioned towards this but
for me it was gonna be new ground yeah
and the plan was to do two total 10
hours of cumulative practice throughout
the day and we got to 6:00 and I just
had nothing left in the tank uh-huh it's
difficult for me to describe what it
feels like to have nothing left in the
tank with regards to meditation but yeah
inherently it's quite a relaxed
environment to be in but when your days
spent silencing your mind noticing
thoughts if they rise into consciousness
labeling them and getting rid of them
and then starting again and focusing on
your breath but it's like doing of what
if the same as dude American misto
dubious yeah but that's right that's
that's what I mean what a lot of people
you worked up that and you kept going on
that and that's obviously saw the stage
that I Martin like my girlfriend she
does it sometimes with me but sometimes
she struggles with these thoughts that
come on whatever comes so but she only
thinks of these false when she tries to
meditate so she tries to keep herself
busy over with so she doesn't think of
these farts yes so she she she's lying
and she's getting back
but what I tried to pass well that's
that's normal that's or care you know
these false welcome you know it's learn
to accept and and like you said pushing
them or side they'll come again accept
[ __ ] Messiah and it's like anything
you know you've got the gym between your
bicep you do it twice you do free and it
gets bigger it gets a little stronger
guess why is it it's exactly the same as
the mind like a sit where you don't fake
seconds to their okay we'll do 40
seconds tomorrow progressive and that's
that's key and it's every day you just
you know just that little Mars up a
little more and then these force become
less you know and then farts I used to
think of in the first 10 seconds you
might not even think about for the first
four minutes told you right I think you
know what what I found especially if my
practice is deepened and Brian my
meditation coach will be listening now
from America what I've realized is my
meditation practice is deepened recently
is not necessarily that the thoughts
don't arise it's that your capacity to
be able to deal with them it's just so
much so much more so much stronger and
the ability to let go yeah you know
that's my rising anyone can just let go
yeah that's the that's the main point
for me learning you know sometimes these
forty regardless these thoughts will
always come the will I believe until I
get deeper off forever who knows but the
force will always come what the
connections with the forces for me who's
got weaker mm-hmm it doesn't identify as
much anymore right yeah exactly so it's
not like the calm that there you go look
um you know where's before the cumin are
black yeah yeah I'm getting really
annoying move it and couldn't fully
understand why I was getting them
forward so I fully understand like why
that was happening and that but now
lastly so well you either there's only
two ways based on the shins on young
book that reading at the moment there's
two things that happen you either
identify with them while you suppress
them so it's an attachment or it's a
suppression yeah and you like right okay
I don't want to do either of those
things because if you try and suppress
thoughts that's still not dealing with
it that's putting a cloth over the topic
a life
yeah exactly it's not working I actually
dealing with it and the same thing is
when you begin to identify with them you
like right okay well now I'm live jumped
into it I don't get to do that either I
just got to accept it for what it is and
let it go so something else that I
really I really wanted to talk about was
your training I think that you know a
lot of people know you online from the
fact that you do online courses and you
are in good condition and stuff like
that how do you think that marrying the
the mindfulness and and the training
stuff and your sport as well as working
on your mind helped you with regards to
you and your performance at football
massively in terms of football I used to
be a I still saw arm because it's out my
game and I really aggressive blur I'm a
scent that made the aggressive the ball
tackler break it or pass it or move it
on they're not so talented one Monday
Vinnie Jones exactly so yeah so but it's
like me as I've got although the
mindfulness is to control these you know
I've got a lot of sending offs back in
my dear but now I'm a bit more bit more
clever about the way I go about things
because like I say the mindfulness has
helped me with a to deal with like you
will always get the odd player whined
and each other up or I always feel like
I could win that mental about of lemon
wine and each other up now you know so
so the the mindful has definitely helped
me on the football pitch and also I like
learning to control situations and heat
at the moment because everything that
arises for me not just in a football but
in life in the gym my first part is
practice it's true it's true
you know so if I become what ever ever
difficult challenge comes ahead perfect
opportunity if for my mind to get
through it now
instead of oh [ __ ] I can't deal with
this for me it's like Oh brilliant this
this problems come on so this is a
perfect opportunity for my mind to
tackle this problem and overcome this
problem and without this problem a man
and get stronger so things like that on
the pitch in my mind like the marvelous
has definitely helped me within the gym
it's made things a lot more clear and a
lot more
acceptable for me you know like I like I
said back an idea where I got really big
and it wasn't acceptable for modeling
and I'd have to trim down for football
you know so that was a bit of a like I
was always battling with things so now I
feel like I found that like that you
know like that Fight Club lane type look
like everyone types like I know I'm not
going to see everyone but majority of
people do like that lean look all each
did wrong I know some of God do
competitions etc etc so but yeah I think
overall the mindfulness I think as
massively helped me and in all
everything I do in my work my football
my gym which is why I like I said which
is why put it into practice like anyone
watching give it a go and put it into
practice and he will see it's not it's
not just me saying it because I want you
to do it our you know our sonic
Commission schemes in it because it's
worked like the the shits like it's it's
a bear wouldn't do so well but this we
won't continue to do some it that's not
work and that's not even you would feel
you know as a good example as well for
yourself you are a a guy that wants to
try and continue to refine different
elements of his life right yeah you're
looking at
I didn't read now I read and didn't
approach football in this way and now I
do and I used to train in this
particular fashion that I found that
this worked that for me you told you
right like do you think that if
mindfulness wasn't working for you that
you just continue to smash your head
against the wall for 15 minutes every
single day no I wouldn't you would do
anything cause you get this thing out of
it I think what do you think is the UK's
or the the normal UK young person's
approach towards when you when you
mentioned mindfulness because sometimes
when I say to people I just get this
look and it's like I I don't know it's
like I've spoken about being a [ __ ]
stunk like yeah going back to my younger
days I oh I would a fire have you told
me when I was a bit younger and probably
in the rebel that I wasn't a little bit
that background but if you told me it
that I'd be like what my first part is
these guys in these dresses and you know
wants to do that and that that's but
probably majority of what a lot of lives
are you allowed to do are on the mir to
be like what you sit there with a monk
you meditate well that's not cool you
know I say but you got the gym in you're
working on your outlook all about try
and work on your inner look and see the
difference in how you feel so it's just
becoming you know more aware and Sean
people it works and and and letting
people accept it you know and and doing
it so so yeah it's one of its I think
it's a bit not Donna but maybe a bit
it's not a bit manly for a man to sit
very very potentially I think that's
that's a good point that you know when
both northern lads so both from T side
like it's not the sort of place that I
heard meditation talked about an awful
lot as I grew up not like and you know
maybe if we were in LA yeah there was
like a Hakim juice bar on every corner
and you know everyone's vegan and
they're you know wearing no not wearing
shoes every walking around [ __ ] then
becomes type cool it's just it's more I
think that kind of more progressive side
of things is there and obviously America
has got a lot of different influences on
it's quite fast moving there's something
inherent as well I think in the British
people that everything's just a bit [ __ ]
yeah Joe mean like everyone's like the
weather's crap yeah is that and I think
everyone tends to be a little bit more
critical about it but what that doesn't
mean that is the route for me that is
the reason why you need to do it yes
finish it exactly so so obviously by
constantly you guy you've got [ __ ]
weather you can't change the weather the
weather's [ __ ] you got [ __ ] traffic if
you had to change that but what you can
change is your feeling and your attitude
towards ax you know and that's where
people feel a [ __ ] traffic [ __ ]
weather yeah you're gonna you're gonna
continue to do that more about that all
your life
are you gonna try and deal with it in
another way so you can sit in the
traffic and upset the traffic so you can
walk out in the rain and enjoy the road
you know and it's not always don't get
me wrong it's not always gonna be like
ah yeah
we all love the song so but it's working
towards I'm making them feelings a
little bit better you know one one we go
to work and we sat in traffic and we
beep an hour or maybe just chill out and
I said well I think well I wrote a wrote
a article that right now we'll be out in
Muscle and Fitness for this this
particular month of the month of
February and it was on mindful muscle I
called it and it wasn't to 9,000 word
testimonial to mindfulness training and
then a couple of prescriptive
meditations that you can do yourself and
in that one of the parting thoughts that
had was that your mind is all that you
have and it's all that you've ever had
and your life shouldn't be spent at the
mercy of the next action or thought that
comes careening into your consciousness
yeah like if you spend your entire life
at the mercy of things that are outside
of your control
you're literally handing your life over
to everything else if you can if you
know that traffic will set you off and
the weather will set you often you
missus having an argument or set you off
and this the other you're literally
handing control of your life
over to something of someone else that
isn't out of your control
it is it was those attack on that there
was some type of diagram a few year ago
that I've seen in terms of like you're
seeing the traffic you know all these
little things that annoy you is that
it's like a bucket type fit and you know
if you get up on the morning and you
stand on summer yeah exactly goes oh
then you go and look for your toothbrush
you can't find it you get more noise the
pocket goes higher you know then you
can't find your car keys it goes higher
then the smallest thing that your light
changes from amber or red just before
you get that far I'm gonna say now the
book overflow so instead of like oh
instead of standing on that plugin right
right okay I've like like let go it's
gone I think bring it back down but like
that's what you want about there's like
little things are no yeah no yeah and
then you'll have this real big outburst
maybe when you get to where you think
two minutes after you think before I
should do now yeah and because it's all
come from these little build ups that
you've not let go of and you're still
holding onto and getting really
aggressive and really annoyed ah you
know I put a straw the broke the camera
but you can't but we can't see that or
because it's within the mind it's as
that all sin of you know if I give you a
hot call and you're on what would be the
first thing you do you'd leave go over
yeah you know also if a fault hurting
you and bringing your pen why you still
walking around will get my Chris you do
my head in you so I'm gonna walk around
off and like that that's that's just
painful you know so like all right
kisses me that's all that go
yeah gone and it's like if people can
visually see that which is what are then
well that if you could visually see that
you'd let go of it's true they say anger
is holding onto a hot coal in the hopes
of throwing it at somebody else exactly
so you just walk around will try to look
for someone else to to let alone the
lowered you yeah and then and then after
that become regret and everything else
yeah one of the things I wanted to move
on to was talking about the platform
that you've got and the other people
have online and what they're using that
for so I mean if you were to try and how
would you define the message that you
want to try and get across to people the
message tried to get across the people
though there's a lot of opportunities
out there to keep learning and
progressive and whatever field you're
working in whatever area you wanted to
improve you know as a lot of stuff out
there and that I'm still learning that
and that's why I'm still progressing
into that I'm just trying to give off
not this luxury life that don't get me
wrong a lot of people like it is good to
output you've got trying that the
journey I'm on is trying to find
happiness from within you know and I'm
putting that back to people what I'm
learning I'm wanting to put back to
people so yeah it's a it's a big journey
but that's one of the main reasons that
I want to use my social on my platform
from I do get I do understand there's a
lot of big people out there that you do
have to use it for some type of income
you know or some work you've got a dude
sponsored poster do get that and there
will be tag where you have to do that
but those the main reasons is obviously
I wanna push out there that he is also
false was not always you know it's not
always look sure
what does what does happiness mean to
you then happiness means to me helping
others progressed within the life and
finding more about themself
I'd like to say so I'm like I said I'm
still learning that about myself so I
can't you know if if my loved ones are
happy around me people who are loved a
comfortable happy and pain-free I feel I
think that that is my overall yeah
it's amazing to have all these luxuries
and attachments that go with it but I
think that because that comes because of
society and what people are pushing on
you he's got a little strainer so I've
got the notebook
would you really get them if it wasn't a
trend if it wasn't a fashion except you
know it's it's it's finding somewhere
else that makes European not someone
that's an attachment yeah I mean the
hedonic treadmill there's a really
interesting study that use of sites all
the time we talked about people who
become disabled and lose the use of
their legs and people who win the
lottery and have like an unlit but
essentially an unlimited amount of money
their self-rated happiness after six
months is the same so they have this
particular baseline of happiness at
monza 0 then this incident occurs and
they split off and then by the time you
get back to six months both of them have
adapted so I think people that presume
that material goods will bring them
happiness are chasing down a endless
treadmill that's not really actually got
anything I recently learned that one of
my courses on meditation oh you know
attachment will eventually cause
software and pen you know if you're
relying on attachment for your happiness
you know I want the next big car okay
I've got that car well no I'm on another
car see you off like your surname
forever Cheers this summer for your
happiness that's all he giving you
temporary happiness and again this is
some a plan and then wanted to book us
in terms of trying to find happiness
from within so I'm just up here just
slightly with each other you know and
like all I do don't get me wrong
not seeing a door like a nice car I
don't like nice claws because that's the
industry that I'm in you know and that's
the industry sometimes I feel like I've
gotta be it to still have the connection
to be able to still speak and pass the
message you still gotta come across cure
and not crazy if you give it if you were
given the choice would you just be in a
pair of elephant pants and barefoot yeah
I really want if that if that if that
was acceptable but again that's me how
can I say if that was acceptable in
terms of because if I just done that now
people a girl and so what's the plot and
no one would listen to me and what I'm
trying to pass out on what I'm trying to
see yeah you know so there's a lot of
celebrities I stood it where people
think oh he's gone crazy but when you
look like Jim Carrey now you go ahead
perfect I was a blast or I was gonna say
Keanu Reeves but it's just just as
mental yeah so yeah so these type people
where people got lost the plot and then
actually if you're looking at what the
China seeing what the China deliver you
know he's for them enlightenment yeah
they're not off to the plot that but a
lot of these people I know he's gone
crazy they're not but that's what I'm
saying if me and you all of a sudden
just therefore elephant park there's a
[ __ ] down yeah I think you've touched
on something that's really interesting
there which is that an easy criticism of
what you've put across and what I what I
put across as well is yeah like good one
mate you talk about all of this
mindfulness bollocks but like you know
you still drive around in a nice car and
you still like wear nice clothes and you
know you still upload topless photos and
stuff
you're not uploading I thought a nice
photo of a piece of tree bark or
something like that and I think the
point that is the dual edged sword of
this is that you still need to play the
game
yeah we have to play the game and as
you've said this is a rule in the rule
that you're given type thing and that
you know
you need to you can't use jump from one
thing and another when people aren't
ready well yeah yeah I mean you need to
capitalize on the effective strategies
within the particular platform that
you're trying to do like it it's all
well and good you being a fantastic
footballer but if you turn up to
practice at the tennis racket it doesn't
matter you're not that you're no longer
playing the game yeah an Instagram has
the social media platform in general it
has a set of rules but I think that one
thing that is very positive is the fact
that you're able to try and put across
an image which is still within that but
on the other side a message which is
maybe trying to progress people's minds
a little bit more you know in ten years
time if you go full jim carrey and
you've got exactly you know it's like a
progression thing where you can see
maybe yeah he's getting he's getting
more perfect what you see and you've got
to play the game until you know you've
got to slowly give them give people what
I'm learning which obviously the people
while I'm learning off that's what I'm
feeling off there because if I just
turned up with a Buddhist monk wondering
I'm here to be Heidi I'm still a lot of
still like I still have a laugh a little
piss about still have a drink I still do
all the large things but in my spare
time I'm still wanting to learn about
myself you know with inside myself yeah
I think it's something that I often get
conflicted about which is that there's
certain elements of the game that needs
to be played with whether it be to do
with club promo or you know for me
particularly one of them is the fact
that I need to use my phone and I need
to continue to use the Instagram
platform and my other socials to grow my
exposure which enables me to put things
that I genuinely value like this podcast
and other projects that I've got coming
up across having to do that whilst not
actually believing in the platform
itself like I you know if I was able to
do in another
way like if I was able to if I was able
to grow my exposure through meditation
hours like meet me on a cushion I mean
so but it's it's difficult do you ever
get conflicted with that with having to
do the Instagram thing whilst you yeah
well like you like you just to step on
that I'd love to you know go to a
meditation class and and you know video
or tip pictures of the meditation which
I do
that'd be the common yeah which which is
what I the way I try to break it up is
my stories for that I'm a meme pages a
marvel of a message Marva you know like
like my project in terms of like my
books my six weeks that I've just put on
that's what I'm wanting to do - well
people so everything that I'm learning
I'm wanting to open that we're so I
still need to I need to practice you
know practice what I preached a fingers
know appoint me sin I'll lean 365 and me
being fat 365 these - exactly so I need
sir it's not that's the message I'm
trying to put cross on my page but with
that with me work on my physique I'm
also trying to show within the captions
that the mind type of things because I
can't exactly show my mind on a picture
but I try to sure what my mind see and I
want my mind's lens
yeah but the image of the picture is the
physique what people want to see on what
the Bonner was she I assume they want to
see maybe do I see differently maybe dad
bods come in baby will do both it sees
if we come back in if we come back in 12
month I'm and dad would do it dad but on
the same so the dad Vaughn just a few
beggars there but yeah like I think you
you're right and for people out there
who are maybe thinking that it's quite
easy to see the lifestyles and stuff to
get put across on the Instagram and take
them at face value but we've got
somebody here you could two people sat
on the same couch who were both saying
that the images that we put across our
us playing the game and still some
people are proud about you know this
photo shoots that I'm sure that you love
in this once
as well and you know I think I can
really really like that photo of me I
think that photos also but it's not me
that's not that's not the essence of who
I am and I don't think it's necessarily
the essence of who you are either it's
like look like if there is someone you
really really idolized think about the
message they're putting across and be
maybe a little bit more critical about
how high of a pedestal should I put this
person on like is it just the fact that
they're good-looking or if they actually
got values that I care about if they
actually got a level of integrity that I
would want for myself and an easy litmus
test the canary in the coal mine for
this is do you genuinely genuinely think
that that person's happy but because for
the most that I know you know both you
and me all know shitload of people that
work a lot on Instagram and have a big
following and this that any of their and
the [ __ ] miserable yeah well that's
why I'm cyd and that's why I preach you
hope the meditation put the land and put
the read and put it into practice
because he has been tabs and there still
is times when I'm a I'm a nappy I still
like a force and feelings when I'm sad
and I'm I'm upset and you know but these
forties feelings these moments have
become easier for me become less of a
problem for me you know I still get him
and will always get him until I get
further maybe maybe the micro or maybe
the one but you know as people it were
constantly still going on about maybe
not going on but still having these
problems and still suffer in these
thoughts and feelings but they do and
nothing come out yeah or which even
doubling down on covering them up yeah
yeah I'll try to item track room from
transit pretend that the happy with the
car the list
cloven like yes that does make you happy
it makes me happy it would make you
happy if you went and bought like
brand-new pair trainers it does is all
but maybe for a short space of time is
not wrong we're still doing that but
also working on yourself from within you
know but is it like the meshes are
trapped but across if you track combine
them both well even all free you know
your lifestyle you live your mindfulness
from within and the look on the outside
in terms of you Fitness whatever that if
you can combined all and free then you
will start to find some
some middle ground of happiness and then
that's some searching for and still
looking at everyday yeah that's awesome
man so before we finish up are there any
resources or books that you would
recommend to people any websites or
blogs that you often visit em well as an
app obviously the car map that we spoke
about I've got as a read enough that I
always use calm media if you have a lot
of mediums fantastic yeah so again any
any topic that you're interested in just
download the app medium search the topic
brings anything up and just have a read
on it again heart and the only like ten
five minutes 15 minutes little articles
that you can read and find some really
useful information this car you got
seven days trial so you can do seven
days if you don't feel anything from it
you don't if you do you can get the app
for a bit longer
more version manifestos one the best
books are read maybe try and find you
one of your local buddhist centers give
it a go see how you feel
again it's putting these things into
practice like i'll be the first to say I
wasn't a best reader at school as I'm
still not now you know like which is why
I'll only reach for 15-20 minutes max
half an hour I'm not one of these who
can sit and read for two free hours to
go in it yeah okay my head just goes all
over and I'm thinking of this finger
that but it's getting better you know
and a lot of my mates and even my family
like what you read now mm-hmm I was
probably the last thing I'd ever think
of you know when I was back at school
even in college when I played for both
males bruh because I just didn't get it
but now I get it I get what the doing
the work and on it doesn't even have to
be working might be just really nice
story that you're flying good licks in
yeah just getting lost like it's just
sometimes in a book you just like you
know say well you just get lost of
what's actually out there you know and
disengage from everything else and it's
relaxing and it's peaceful so yeah read
the reading as highly performance of its
is it Brendan butcher's I can't high
performance Alex that's one that's a
really good book in terms of business
and apply it maybe what goals you've got
maybe what ambition
you've got and getting the best out of
yourself getting the best out of your
team what's around you the resources and
so that book was good for that so yeah
that's a few things that I'm a massive
fan of medium we spoke about on the life
at previous life hacks episode but it's
just like the best curated news site
that you've ever heard of so imagine the
top filtering of every blog on the
planet and it's submitted the apps
beautiful it remembers your place you
can get suggestions Sanchi it's like if
Facebook was meant for learning [ __ ]
yeah like an every it's like oh you
recently read something about
cryptocurrency so here's something else
that kind of is associated with darkness
learns of attack I absolutely love it
I'm a massive massive fan yeah so Leon
where can the listeners find you online
and you can find me on the Instagram
Leon free Scott or you can find me on my
website it's just Leon - got calm and if
there's anything you want to ask me just
drop it in my comments of radius
there's picture or DM me there was
anything not with I'll find the time
I'll get back to you man it's been a
pleasure thank you very much travel you
know thank you.thank next
[Music]
you